our second meeting back in the chamber
as you will recall from the last time we
have a capacity limited of no more than
22 people in the room
in order to make sure that we don't go
over that limit some of the offices will
be joining us by soon
the meeting will be live streamed and
the recording will then be placed on the
council's website
item one on our agenda are apologies for
absence
yes chair we've received apologies from
councillor rouse
thank you
no other apologies
and on the seizure
item two declarations of interest
councillor liggett
yeah um i won't without voting on the
brackenfield application so i'm going to
go out to the room thank you
councillor will you be speaking
no okay thank you
i will be leaving the room chair thank
you
members are requested to declare any of
the existing and nature of any
disposable community interests and or
other interests not already on their
register of interests
in any item on the agenda and with
withdrawal we've had that from
councillor are there any further
applications
no non the future thank you
the first application is item four and
sorry we're at the minutes at the moment
i'm ahead of myself again
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the minutes of our meeting i hope
everyone's managed to have a copy of
these i know some members didn't get
paper copies in advance
thank you is there a seconder thank you
all those in favor
any against
any abstentions
the motion's been carried
the main business
thanking members that moves us on to our
main business for today we have three
substantial items to consider
we will also receive an update on the
current section 106 agreements
as you can see each of the items has its
own report with the section 106 update
to be taken at item 8.
i am happy with this and intend to
consider the reports in this order
before we do i would like the client to
explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching on youtube
how we will deal with the applications
right thank you chair
this is the procedure for considering
applications at the meeting
we will consider the three applications
in the order that they are set out on
the agenda
although there will be a break after
each item to allow our speakers for them
to arrive
the chair will introduce the item then
ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
planning officers will then give a brief
presentation setting out the application
plans and photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask each of
the speakers any ward members first
followed by objectors
then the applicant or their agent to
speak to the committee
each speakers will have three minutes to
put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes members of the committee will
have an opportunity to ask the queen to
ask the speaker questions if necessary
to clarify any points they have made
when we have heard from all the speakers
on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate
and determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
once the application which the speakers
have come to um
and so give a contribution on has been
dealt with they may leave the chamber
if they choose to remain however that
they will not be allowed to participate
further in the meeting from that point
they will also be required to leave the
chamber once the committee has decided
on the application which they've spoken
on
as you're aware this meeting is being
live streamed on the council's website
and obviously others may choose to copy
this from the internet or from the
internet
thank you chair
thank you we'll move on to the first
application which is ned for slash 21 4
00938
fl at brackenfield
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning manager and
officers to tell us about any late
comments reports that have been produced
and to give a brief description
presentation showing any photos and
plans of the site
i will allow the offices to complete the
presentation
consequently members could you please
reserve any points of order or questions
about the process until the end
there will be plenty of times for
questions later on excuse me church
shall i now bring the uh speakers who've
arrived into the room thank you
helen if if i may
like you're able to arrange for me to
share my screen for the presentation
please
adrian i noticed when we spoke then we
couldn't hear you would you mind just
trying again
is that can you hear me now
no we can't hear you just bear with me
i'm just going to resolve that
adrian could you try again for me
please can you hear me now
no okay just bear with me
apologies we just have a slight
technical edge
would you be able to just admit yourself
and speak
yeah hello can you hear me
no we can't so we've just got a little
bit of a technical issue we're going to
resolve
jim if it helps i can hear you can you
yeah
i can hear you agent yes
there must be something in the council
chamber
i can't um
can anyone hear me to allow me to share
my screen so we can get any presentation
up from the guidelines
yeah i've sent a sent a message to the
governance team sir
someone else who might be better placed
you think
see if i can get hold of the
martin
adrian could you try again for us
can you hear me now
yes we can that's wonderful thank you
just while you're there nikki are you
ready to ask somebody to allow me to
share my screen so i can bring the
presentation
oh yeah no problem just give me a moment
thank you
you should have rights now
and it looks like we're off thank you
adrian
thank you chair and before i go into the
video so just to a brief introduction
for members for the
first application which is nad 21
0 0 9 3 8 the fl for the demolition of
two poly tunnels in the erection of a
single dwelling on land to the north of
school farm church lane south of
conlon's at carlene at brackenfield and
firstly terrifying may refer members to
the late comments report that was issued
yesterday
as members saw on the site yesterday
chair this application seeks consent to
construct a single dwelling on an
agricultural area of land
dwelling would be 1.5 stories high and
occupied primarily the site two existing
polytunnels
brackenfield is no settlement boundaries
chair so the site lies in countryside
for planning purposes
where new development is strictly
controlled it's also located in area of
multiple environmental sensitivity
chairs defined in the publication draft
local plan
specifically in this case chair the
development plan policies of both your
own local plan and the breckenfield
neighborhood plan seek to ensure new
housing is restricted to small
small-scale in-field development sites
protect important views and ensure that
the character of the area is protract is
protected
officers conclude in this case share the
proposal is not in-field development and
neither fails to protect views or the
character of the area
overall chair officers consider the
reason set out in the report the
proposal does not conform with the
policies of the development plan
and it would adversely impact the
character of the area and there are no
other issues that outweigh those
considerations
and just to reflect share on the
content of the site visit yesterday the
application site
outlined as you can see on the screen
it currently contains two poly tunnels
which are
year chair and another building here and
it has
consent for its use for agricultural
purposes in this case horticulture
the
apologies
the application site again the chair
outlined in red with other land and all
controlled by the applicant in blue and
the location that you dwelling would be
here chair with some parking and turning
facilities and the retention of the
building that's currently on the site
in oblique form new dwelling in that
location
retention of the building that we'll see
on the photographs in a second
will be brackenfield
the site and the imperial decision
that's referred to in the papers chair
occupies this portion of land here
in terms of
larger scale drawing two pond polytons
you can see outlined and shaded on this
clan chair and then the proposed
dwelling you see superimposed on them
with the parking and turning facilities
the retention of the storage shed
and in terms of elevations these are the
two
side elevations of the proposed building
and then the the front
and
the rear
that's a
visual
of the proposed dwelling
and just some um photographs just to
remind members of what we saw on the
side yesterday
this site
is consent to be used for horticultural
by agricultural purposes there is two
polytunnels you can see in the
foreground and the building in the
background which will be retained should
consent be granted
and looking from the side towards
brackenfield
this is seeking to show share the
relationship of the site with other
nearby but
adjacent
premises and these form the dwellings
that i've referred to there's this area
of space and gap here to refer to the
report and the appeal
site is occupying this area here and
that was an appeal for two dwellings
that was dismissed on appeal then
relatively recently
eventually looking back from
the access here that is the public
footpath referred to and you can see the
existing development on the site the two
polytunnels from the other building
that's referred to
and finally chair another view of that
from a slightly different angle this is
the
discussion that we uh i just say
regarding the the views that are
referred to in the brackenfield
neighborhood plan
i think that's all on this
chair thank you
i'll intend to stop being sharing my
screen shout out if
you want me to
to bring the presentation back up then
do please uh let me know
thank you adrian
i'm now going to invite the speakers to
address the committee as the clerk
explained they will each have three
minutes
to get over their points they will be
informed when 30 seconds remain
as members you can ask them to clarify
any matters that have been raised but
remember your question should only
relate to the points which have already
been made
now speakers will address us from the
table that's in front of you
and the first speaker is the award
member councillor charlotte cooper
three minutes when you're ready
just
is that working yeah sounds better than
drumfield
so i'm speaking on this as one of the
ward members to outline my concerns
about this application i think the
officer report is pretty clear
particularly the summary from paragraphs
8.1 to 8.9
the first key concern for me is the
impact of these proposals on the
distinct and rural character of
brackenfield which is recognised in
policy as the officers just outlined
other houses have recently been built
and given permission in other parts of
the village as infill in line with
policy so it's not a no houses desire
here but the issue rather and the
concern of many residents is the really
open nature of the site and crucially
its surroundings including its setting
within augustan reservoir and valued
local views indeed there's even a
popular heritage and nature trail in the
village now and there's a film crew in
the village as well today
um i know this is only one house but the
recent appeal decision on this same site
was clear in dismissing development of
this area whilst the appeal was for a
surprise was for a different application
in a different part of the plot the
inspector was surprisingly clear and
categoric on the importance of this area
as a gap so quote the gaps between
buildings in this area are an integral
component of the local distinctiveness
and the inspector also recognized the
weight the neighborhood plan affords to
historic views
um and this this application would i
think interrupts those views
unfortunately still even with the
previous proposals of the dormer
bungalow
and the current proposal the inspector
also categorically stated that the
personal circumstances of any applicant
didn't override these concerns
with this the second key point for me is
that i don't consider this site as
previously developed as the officer
report details the polytunnels should
have been removed when the site was
stopped being used as a nursery so they
shouldn't be used as justification as
the site is still a green field in rural
space to consider it as otherwise could
have ramifications elsewhere
i understand personal circumstances have
been put forward as mitigating
circumstances in this application and
i'm genuinely really sorry but i just
don't believe these can override the
clear officer recommendation as well as
the objections of the parish council
residents and the neighbourhood plan
group
regardless of personal sympathy here i
think both the councils and the
neighborhood plan policies are clear and
the neighborhood plan passed with an
overwhelming and strong majority because
the village wants to protect its unique
and moral character
these policies shouldn't be bypassed
particularly given the recent appeal
decision as it would risk harm not just
this site but potentially set wider
precedence and consequences so i support
the officer recommendation of refusal
here
thank you are there any questions
[Music]
i probably can't speculate but i know
since i've been a counsellor
2015 i've never seen any movement there
and i think it's changed ownership i
don't know a few times
any further questions council foster
thank you chair uh just one question
counselor cupid um
when you look at all the policies i know
you'll be familiar uh with the policies
uh around the neighborhood plan and the
brackenfield so the practical
neighborhood plan and our local plan
is there anything in there to your
knowledge that promotes building like
this in this area
no i think the policies are clear there
was an application recently um on the
other side of the road on the centre of
the village for an infill house and that
that was approved under office of
recommendation and didn't have any local
objection whereas this is considered
in my view and an interview quite a few
residents to be
in the rural gap
thank you any further questions
no thank you counselor
okay
and the next speaker is mr andrew
tollatin
three minutes when you're ready
uh i've been asked to speak on behalf of
the brackenfield neighbourhood planning
for meditation and monitoring group they
would have sent a representation to him
unfortunately they can't come uh while
vanessa is emphasized the continued
strong objection to this unacceptable
proposal which should be refused
uh this not reflects my own views but
also many people in the community and
reflect the number of objections you've
received to the planning application and
other members of the community have been
here
also the office has recommended it for
refusal so it's your determination but i
think it's fully justified
i mean essentially this is just a
modified version of the two previous
applications both of which
were refused
one of which went to appeal and as i
said the inspector wholeheartedly
rejected it i don't see this materially
different than the previous applications
in particular what it seeks to do is
build a dwelling on a greenfield site in
the open countryside and an unsuitable
and unsustainable location
it's in country to establish national
local planning policies not only those
contained in the neighborhood plan which
was but also the ones in your emerging
local planning your current local plan
and is unlocked contributing national
planning policy and i'll give you
examples of that later
it does not represent sustainable
development which we'll talk later and
if approved would create a dangerous
precedent for the building of similar
homes in the countryside across the
whole of the district if you allow this
potentially you'll see similar planning
applications going across the whole of
the district
turn into more details of the objections
it's as the planning i've said it's it's
an agricultural site in the open
countryside
it is it is and there's never been
previously developed land the gentleman
here is going to touch on that
in flowering terms it's in the open
countryside it's outside the settlement
development limits shouldn't be
surprised there is strong policies which
don't support the building of new
dwellings in the countryside this is in
the countryside
it is not in full site
you know there's an infographic normally
a a small gap with an otherwise built up
frontage this is a large gap
indeed the government inspector and took
the planning on the previous application
not only concluded
that this wasn't infilled but this gap
was as the council imagined this was
this gap was integral to the character
of the area
it is it it won't improve the look and
appearance of the area
i mean it's it's urban development we're
talking about
i mean it's contrary to
i've got 14 policies listed mainly from
the inspector's report from your
office's report these included local
plan policies gs1 gs6 me1 h03 the
policies ch1 ch2 and and h1 the neighbor
plan policies ss1 entertainment
under the propaganda draft local plan
and he's not coming to national planning
policy
goodness and policy hateful in the
brecken david plan which does support
houses in very special circumstances
this is not
the so-called circumstances and also
there's a load of policies which talk
about protecting local character
important important views
and the and the wild lives like this
does not and the last points allowed to
make
is it sustainable location if you allow
development here
racquetball has got very things people
have to drive to get to local services
it's not suitable it's not sustainable
for these it should be refused thank you
thank you
are there any questions
councillor foster then councillor
armitage
thank you chair uh mr tilton
um
uh i'm guessing you had something to do
with the the neighbourhood yeah i'll
trust the labour plan yeah okay uh could
you provide some clarity uh he's
referred to the neighborhood plan policy
h1
in 7.3 on page 17 and it's described as
more permissive but there's no more in
this uh on that uh oh i'll describe that
policy yeah i mean what that does in
terms of the built-up part of
breckenfield loosely the neighborhood
plan is a bit more permissive in terms
of what happens within the built-up part
of brackenfield
in terms of the outside the countryside
the policies similar to your own
policies you know this is contrary to
neighbor plan policy uh
you know if we were talking about a
small
if it was a small gap in an otherwise
built up frontage potentially
also if it's providing affordable
housing potentially but this doesn't
meet the criteria
which we're not which would potentially
out which is we've seen is potentially
more permissive in the neighborhood plan
than the emerging local plants although
it's referred to in here has been more
permissive it's not applicable to this
area no no i mean it's it is but no it's
not relevant to this he would not allow
this development my personal opinion
thank you chair
thank you council armitage
thank you
uh
when you drew up the plan
uh
apart from infill were there any areas
which considered uh
suitable for development
are
is the village devoid of any development
the the general policy which is
reflected in the local plan as well is
that in in exceptional circumstances
development within the
settlement development limits which is a
sort of built up part of the village
would be suitable
in certain circumstances you might allow
affordable housing outside of those
limits but they would be the only real
uh you know
basically it focuses development towards
what is loosely the
built-up part of brackenfield
so where does the uh
settlement development limit
lie it's well it's local planetary it
it's around it's not it hasn't got
settled
the settlement development limit will be
established at a local plant that's the
key tool which will apply the the the
the determinant that we have settlement
development limits or not the neighbor
plan didn't determine the settlement
development limit
but what it did say was within the sort
of
built-up part of breckenfield if you
would say that in-field development
might be suitable this is not in full
development
partly because it was determined that
was best for the local plan to determine
if the settlement if there should be a
subtle developmental image or not
yes i think i know what you're saying
sorry
any further questions
no thank you
our next speaker is mr graham keaton
mr keaton three minutes when you're
ready
hello good afternoon um before i just do
my little thing i'd just like to answer
a previous question the nursery never
really did anything and completely
finished in 2010
right now this is what i want to say
this planning that this planning
application has been going on for four
years and this is the fifth attempt it's
all very worrying stressful and
upsetting
the site is in countryside a green
agricultural field and should not be
built on
polytunnels cannot be counted the same
as a house they're completely different
you can you can expect to see a
political field but not a house
the idea that this is sustainable is
nonsense every visit here will be by car
the services we have in brackenfield are
minuscule
only thing being one bus a day to
matlock and one to play across
the community only gets together perhaps
once a year at the picnic so the
applicants claiming that they're
currently in the local community is
purely a sound bite
this field is very important to the
rural nature of brackenfield
as supported and evidenced by the
neighborhood plan
the granting of this application would
give absolute zero benefits to our
hamlets and would be the beginning of
the end for brighton fields and would
also set the precedent for every polling
on the northeast derbyshire to be turned
into a house
that's it
thank you are there any questions
oh thank you you can take yourself
and the next speaker is the applicant
mrs kathleen walker
three minutes when you're ready mrs
walker
good afternoon
being part of the farming community
myself a farmer's daughter from matlock
and my husband are involved in farming
and agricultural contracting it has
always been our dream to create a small
holding which will include an orchard
and sheep so we can enjoy the land with
our children and grandchildren
in 2016 we were fortunate to be able to
purchase leefield nursery we wanted to
build on the site of the pony tunnels
and leave the field however we were
advised by a planning consultant to
apply for permission on the land
opposite the semi-detached houses on car
lane
but this was refused due to visual
impact
we attended a parish council meeting
when it was suggested that building the
property on the side of the polytunnels
would be the preferred place
we changed planning consultants and we
initially applied to replace the barn
but the reality is that we need the barn
to manage our land so we withdrew that
application as a family we had a rethink
and it was advised that we should
consider building on the location of
polytunnels which the council would like
to see removed this fitted with what the
parish council has said to us i would
ensure that our home was positioned next
the road trees
instead of the open field
as five years has now passed we are
increasingly keen to become a more
integral part of this community by
building a dormer bungalow on the site
of the polytunnels
and making efficient use of our land for
agricultural we regularly spend time at
our site since we have owned it we have
significantly tidied up the land by
removing the raised beds and we receded
the area so that we could sustain
several sheep over the summer
we provided photographs of the
improvements to the planning officer
over the years we've accumulated a
vintage tractor and farm machine which
have been stored on local farmers
including my parents
if you allow us to live at leaffield
nursery we can have everything in one
place in the existing barn and be able
to enjoy using them to work our land
without having to come and go
we want to continue to care for our land
enhance the appearance of the site
encourage wildlife
and become more active members of the
community
the building would be constructed using
local tradesmen and local materials
including stone
we have checked that all the technical
issues can be addressed including
drainage and we are currently living in
rented accommodation which unfortunately
expires at christmas so we will become
homeless we ask the council to look
favorably
to improve the appearance of our land
and charlotte will speak to you about
the planning policies thank you
thank you are there any questions
counselor elliott
because we
because we use the as things in the
polytunnels
instead of having everything outside we
keep things
family things inside
um
just general i do a bit of wood chopping
wood for our log burners that we had in
our house
the kids have got machinery the younger
children have got things so we just tend
to keep stuff out of sight i don't like
to have things out on display
yes
any further questions counselor hancock
thank you chair uh just one um i'm
intrigued with what you said about the
parish council recommending this site i
wonder if you just expand a little bit
more on what was said to you at the time
right when we when i went um before
originally was going to go in with our
son who's now bought at westington so
he's out the equation it's just me and
my husband
and what
we
could you just sorry repeat the question
right we i took on you know the the
design he showed you with the green
field and the polytunnels i lifted the
two i cut a second copy out of the two
pictures of the original houses and i
moved them right down the other end of
the field and we put them in the line
where the polytunnels because these
gravel there and quite a bit and their
opinion was if we went back spoke to our
planning consultant they would look more
favorable at that space because we still
have the field we would have the
bungalow and then next door towards over
that hedge there is not there's two more
properties so even though we're not in
line that end
the other end we are there's a conlons
and then this sycamore farm
mrs walker i have one question looking
at my notes here
it's put that the brackenfield parish
council objects to the proposal did they
notify you when they were going to
object to it no
okay
thank you
any further questions
no thank you very much
and there we have the agent
charlotte stanton three minutes
charlotte
thank you
cath has explained their wish to live on
their property improving and farming
their land and to become more active
members of the community
there are no technical objections the
highway authority coal authority and
environmental health all raise no
objection and drainage can be controlled
by condition
we need to stress to you today that the
previous appeal related to two dwellings
and not one and was for a completely
different site in the blue lined open
field which you saw on the location plan
earlier
the appeal decision stated that the
principle of those two dwellings was
acceptable
the inspector dismissed the appeal on
the basis of the visual impact of the
two dwellings in the open field due to
concerns about blocking views the dormer
bungalow now proposed would not be in
the open field it would replace the
commercial polytunnels and be adjacent
to a substantial barn and the row of
large trees
this revised
position for the bungalow would not
block any views across the countryside
to the east
the important view in the loca in the
neighborhood plan is across the open
field and not this site where any views
are already blocked by the large bar
this application is materially different
to the one that was dismissed as appeal
and you can legitimately reach a
different conclusion
the proposed dwelling would sit next to
the existing residential property known
as conlons and the whole area at
conlon's to the north of the site has
already been approved by the council as
domestic garden this is not an isolated
location
the officer is confirmed at 7.7 that the
proposed design is not out of keeping
during the course of the application we
made it very clear the applicants are
willing to amend the design materials
levels landscaping and boundaries to
suit the council's requirements
if the council is concerned about height
the property can be dug in if there are
concerns about the position or
orientation of the dwelling or the
windows these could be changed but the
officer confirmed that they had no
concerns about the design so we were not
given any opportunities to make changes
one of the issues that kath and david
are really struggling to understand is
that the council granted planning
permission for the bungalow on school
lane only 110 metres from their
application site and this permission was
granted in august this year less than
two months ago
in granting that permission the council
concluded that this location is a
sustainable one
what's the difference
this storm of bungalow would be
positioned against a substantial tree
boundary replace the polytunnels and be
next to the large barn it would not
block views we ask you please to
consider whether this proposed three bed
dorma bungalow would really cause
significant harm thank you
thank you are there any questions
councillor foster councillor armitage
thank you chair uh ms stenton um
when you've described this application
you've compared it to the previous uh
application
uh on that site and you also compared it
to one made in august down the road
perhaps as agent if you can
make your comments for me uh
if you make them relative to the
the policies that we've we've got to
look at so when we're considering um
this this application what i would like
from you as an agent if that's okay is
perhaps more comments on how if our
policies apply to it and the
neighborhood plan policies
too please
yeah as you've heard earlier the the
appeal inspector pointed out that
actually the neighborhood plan policies
are more permissive
than the current local plan policy so
that's the adopted local plan policies
um
the
brackenfield does not have a settlement
development limit
so you heard a previous speaker
referring to the fact that development
is acceptable in brackenfield but as
long as it's within the settlement limit
well we don't have a situation where we
have that clear demarcation we
we're not told in any policy document
where new development is acceptable
so what you have to do as decision
makers is consider each case on its
merits as you're often told to do and
decide whether or not you consider this
development to result in significant
harm
as you know you don't currently have
up-to-date local plan policies so you're
relying on the national
planning policy framework to guide you
towards what is sustainable and what
isn't
in the context of the neighborhood plan
so there is certainly a policy context
there which
has regularly resulted in planning
permission being granted in criminal
side areas outside settlement
development limits and for replacement
buildings including agricultural
buildings all across the district over
the last few years i hope that helps
it does just one small point chair if i
might continue that same point um
you're right about we don't have a local
plan in place uh yet but it's it's been
there publicized already it's been uh
published uh and we have to we we know
here we have to put a certain weight to
that already because of the uh the state
it's uh the current state it's our uh
it's it's progress thank you
sorry was that a question
no i'm just i'm i'm i'm what i'm trying
to do i'll put that question in uh to
offices because you've said we've got to
look at the adopted local plan but here
we know from previous applications that
we do have to put weight on the emerging
local plan
as decision makers that's
your decision how much weight to put
that's right yeah
thank you
thank you council armitage
thank
you uh
it's been claimed that the
property is not sustainable but uh
across the way
there's another house that was passed i
mean is that sustainable or why was it
passed and it wasn't even shown
on the map
on the plan
[Music]
i i have a problem with this because we
can't on the one hand argue that it's
not sustainable to build in brackenfield
and then on the other hand
100 meters away grant planning
permission for a bungalow and each case
does have to be considered on its merits
but we don't have a blanket ban on
development in brackenfield as as
has been presented in some of the
objections
you need to look at this individual case
and the visual impact that it will have
and the inspector was clear that the
principle is acceptable it's about the
visual impact and whether or not that's
acceptable and the visual impact of this
kit of this proposal is significantly
different to the appeal case
yeah uh and we do seem to be missing one
or two things uh i mean we've had the
view
uh
across the field from the open side
but
we never had a view from the other side
where it shows
surely the uh
close proximity to not
there's a very available existing barn
on the site which will remain the
substantial trees down the side of the
site which will remain um
and
the
views that the inspector was concerned
about would not be obstructed by this
development
thank you
adrian
no you can't i'm sorry you've spoken
adrian could you bring up the site
please of the view from the gate
we'll share if you just bear with me a
second thank you
is that one chair or this is that one
it's the one from the site gate i was
referring to
it's before that that one
the ones that
is put forward are the ones showing yes
from the open countryside but it doesn't
show the one from the other side which
shows that it's not in open countryside
and that that was my argument you mean
from the side where the dwellings are
yeah yes sorry i misunderstood your
question the on the other side of that
hedge
is a house yeah and a very large
domestic garden that's been approved by
the council
no there isn't one that should
there certainly isn't a picture of the
neighboring house
councilor richway
yeah i'm just curious about the height
of this building um you say it's a
three-bedroom dormer
is it as big as a house i mean surely if
it was going to be a bungalow a bungalow
three-bedroom bungalow if you took the
dorm apart away
perhaps we may not be here looking at
the impact side of it i don't know
well
it's certainly not as high as a house
the as i said earlier the applicants are
absolutely willing to work with the
council if you'd be more happy to see a
bungalow we can look at a bungalow we've
just had no guidance at all on what may
be acceptable um the reason that we did
the design like this was to keep the
footprint compact um and to respect the
footprint of the existing polytunnels
and generally try to not end up with
something that could be considered to be
sprawling or
as an l-shape we thought that that was a
nice compact simple design in local
materials
what we could do is dig it in as i did
same in my speech if you want to control
the levels we've got no problem with
that at all
just yes briefly and then counselor hall
yeah uh through the chair please on the
website there is actually
maybe the best
uh
what you've requested about in an
elevation shot
there is a
location plan sorry that's what i was
looking for um maybe that's what um
the counselor was wanting to say i don't
think
but there is there is a shot
not a shock but a drawing of the
neighbouring house and the close
proximity to it yeah that's what that's
what we submit to councillor um the
point i was making is that there are no
photos of the fact there's a house next
door
okay that's our armitage
yeah
on the shot uh looking down onto them
the road seems considerably higher
than what the actual where the sight is
going to be could you confirm the
difference in height if there is a
difference
there's a significant slope down the
site from
the lane
down to the barn at the bottom so again
that photograph from taken from the gate
demonstrates a very
significant slope which is why i was
saying it really does give us the
opportunity to dig the property in and
use the levels and work with the levels
thank you are there any further
questions counselor earlier
[Music]
[Music]
the reason that we've applied in full
was so that you know exactly what you're
getting when you grant an outline
planning permission you've no idea
whether we're going to come back with a
five bed
family
massive house whereas if we apply in
full we're being upfront this is what
kath and david want to live in um you
know exactly what it would look like and
there's no secret so that's why i advise
them that the full route was the best
way forward on this
i understand but we could have been sat
here with an outline application and you
may have raised concern about what it
would look like how big it would be
etc so that's why we took that decision
any further questions
thank you thank you
i'll now ask for if there's any
questions to the officers
council elliot councillor armitage
excuse me council early could you use a
microphone thank you
i'll try and shout through this i just
uh
like adrian to probably explain
um what what he what he makes of the
local plan or the emerging local plan
and the settlement development limit if
he can give us a bit of guidance because
i know mr tallinn who wrote a lot of
this and he's certainly done it the same
in my area
is
is formed the opinion that the
settlement development was amongst the
nucleus of the village should we say the
built-up area as he puts it and not in
the outlying stretches of fields wonder
if adrian could just give us a bit of an
insight to that one
just in terms of the settlement
development limit issue per se
as set out in the report there is no
settlement development limit for
brackenfield
therefore there is no
area that within which you would say the
principle of development is acceptable
and outside of this more restrictive
policies would apply therefore there is
no
delineation and therefore for planning
purposes
this site is within the countryside
where you would expect more restrictive
policies to be
outlined and followed
but the the debates
that
you may have in a second must follow the
principle what do the policies of the
development plan say first of all that
has to be your starting point what is
your conclusion in respect of them
and then are there any other material
considerations that outweigh that so
it's it's a relatively straightforward
process and i'd advise members to follow
that logic in coming to your conclusion
just in terms of the development plan
the fact that your current extant local
plan is elderly i was adopted in 2005
doesn't make it out of date and not part
of your consideration
you need to consider whether its
policies are in conformity with the
national planning policy framework
and if they are you can place weight on
those policies so the fact that it is
a plan adopted in 2005 doesn't mean you
should disregard it
in that regard
the policies of that plan seek to ensure
that countryside areas at which this is
one
it's protected from inappropriate
development it's likely to adversely
impact the character of that area
in addition to that chair the
brackenfield neighborhood plan
is an adopted part of the development
plan it was adopted
very recently
in terms of years i think it was to that
2019
therefore you should place weight
commensurate with that
time of adoption on its policies and in
that respect again i would advise the
bracketville neighborhood plan is very
clear in that it only permits
small-scale in-field development and
you've heard mr talton give his view on
what in-field development is and i would
concur with him
this site does not represent in-field
development planning terms
therefore that would lead to conclude
that breckfield neighborhood plan in
that respect
was against this form of development on
top of that chair there is the policies
in respect to important views
and otherwise
backing up the policies in the extant
local plan in respect of character and
appearance of the area and again as
officers we will conclude quite clearly
on those elements
this proposal is contrary to those
policies and then finally chair as
i think councillor foster discussed you
have your publication traffic plan which
is getting well on down the line towards
adoption now therefore you can place
weight on it and its policies
commensurate with that stage of
preparation
and in its regard again it reinforces
what the bradford neighborhood plan says
in regard to very small infield
development within settlements such as
brackenfield and also in respecting the
character of the area and as set out
in the report again shared the area of
multiple environmental sensitivity which
this is one of those sites where you've
heard finding inspectors recently place
great weight on that so
in terms of plan policy chair as
officers we will conclude that clearly
this site is contrary to your
development policies
then it's a matter for members to weigh
whether you believe there are other
material matters that way that
harm to policy and i personally heard
nothing this afternoon that in my
opinion would outweigh that and i would
as always chair ask members to be very
wary of how much weight you place on the
personal
circumstances that have been set out for
you this afternoon because they are not
necessarily ones that you can control
through any planning permission
conditions and may change very quickly
and rapidly therefore be lost
i hope that helps perhaps a bit longer
than council elite would have wished but
i hope that's that's helpful
thank you council armitage
yeah it's uh too aging really it's all
very interesting
to quote one policy and then another
but we've we've had two appeals where
one inspector said little weight should
be put on the emerging one
and then another one said great weight
should be put on the so it it makes us
you know
where do we go from here
as far as i can see
uh
but where would you advise us on this
adrian
as to which policy we use when we
consider that two
uh
inspectors have both said the opposite
to each other
the
advice i'm going to give to members
chair is that recently inspectors have
been placing greater and greater weight
on your publication draft local plan
but as i said
started my response counselor elliot
your extant local plan can still carry
full weight if its policies are in
conformity with the national planning
policy framework
this instance chair protection of
countryside areas from inappropriate
development to my mind is fully
compliant with the
mppf and so
as far as i'm concerned you can place
weight on that policy and
the full weight that it would otherwise
attract but in this case you've also got
the second element of the development
plan which is the bracket for your
neighborhood plan recently adopted
and
again sure that its policies are clear
in in my opinion
and are clear in how you should be
determining the application and that is
to resist this form of development on
this side
i hope that helps again chair
thank you are there any further
counsellor foster
thank you chair uh mr kirkham um just to
provide some confirmation uh to how i
should be looking at this uh to me it
looks like i've got four policies i
should be looking at four plans and
policies within those plans i've got the
extent local plan the emerging local
plan
the neighbourhood plan and the mppf
uh out of those four
uh against that i've got to weigh
material considerations
and
it says on page 25 that in your view
there's no material considerations uh my
concern uh so i'm looking for
confirmation in that that's correct my
concern is because we've been discussing
an awful lot
of other other issues we've been
discussing the slope the polytunnels how
long the business has been there things
which i've never considered planning
considerations including whether
somebody's going to be homeless by
christmas
um
so just confirmation that i'm thinking
in the right direction we've got those
four plans to look at and no material
considerations thank you chair
just in respect of that chain just to
reiterate the the starting point has to
be the development plan so you should be
determining all applications in
accordance with the policies of the
development plan unless material
considerations indicate otherwise
in this case the development plan is the
local plant in the brackenfield
neighbourhood plan
the
they are they are the primary elements
um they are the development plan per se
your other considerations will be your
publication draft local plan and its
policies
and the mppf
and then other matters that you may take
into account
so in essence cancer fosters right is
the development plan first what is your
conclusion in respect to your reading of
those as a whole
and if you were minded further to those
policies to conclude that they are
contrary to this
proposal and you're looking at any other
matters that might outweigh that
and in that respect you've got your
publication draft local plan which is
nearing adoption you can place weight on
its policies in my view but i don't
think that contradicts
your development plan considerations nor
do i consider the mppf would outweigh
your development plan considerations
in terms of other matters that is
ultimately for for you have met for you
as members but you must take a view as
to whether on your conclusion on the
development plan policies whether they
outweigh that
conclusion
and
you may consider that site-specific
issues are so materialist to outweigh
that
that consideration
um
but in this case as officers
we don't believe there are any other
matters that outweigh that size specific
issues or other elements that we've
talked about just in terms of the
agricultural issues council foster
raised chair
agricultural development as on this side
means that this site is not previously
developed land so you shouldn't take
into consideration an element of where
this site is previously developed or
because it's agriculture now you've
heard from one of the speakers at least
the form of developed on this site is
one that you would normally expect
someone in the countryside and if you
were minded to
outweigh that
by saying that a new dwelling on the
side would be
beneficial
i agree that that sets quite a difficult
starting point for the considerations of
similar applications all over the
district and just finally share the the
issue of
the personal matters i i emphasize again
the members to be very
careful in how much weight you put on
personal
circumstances put before you they are
transient and suddenly by nature can't
be controlled necessarily by planning
condition
and can change very rapidly um and be
left not pertinent to about how
development takes place the development
takes place and goes with the land
not necessarily with the persons or the
applicants in this case
i hope that's that's helpful
thank you are there any other questions
no thank you adrian
this leads us to the final part of the
process our discussions about what we've
heard what we think and what we would
just want to decide but before going any
further i would like the clerk to remind
us about motions
[Music]
right thank you chair
you please bear in mind members that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then their amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendations
then the member who has moved the motion
must give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues
and be supported by evidence as
necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations fails
or in other words it is not passed
that doesn't mean to say
that the recommendations are
automatically approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or another
course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
in terms of the timing of motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard read and
discussed the evidence before it
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached
and will then invite some motions to be
put
members will be reminded of this by the
clerk if they wish to uh propose a
motion before then
thank you chair
thank you i'll open the floor for debate
if anyone wants to
no
in which case i will put a motion
forward and that is to recommend we
agree with officers recommendations
second that chad
go to the phone
thank you chair members if you could uh
clearly state fought against or abstain
from the motion to refuse counsel
armitage
against
councillor cooper
councillor elliott
councillor foster four
councillor hall
four
councillor hancock
against
cancer hearts on against
cancer jones
games
counselor oh carefully it's not here
sorry uh councillor powell
castle ridgeway against
and councillor rough four okay that's
six votes four five against zero
abstentions so the motion to refuse is
carried
thank you thank you ladies and gentlemen
um i think we're going to have a short
break yes that would be marvelous chair
uh say 10 minutes would that be ok chair
thank you
do application of twenty one forward
slash zero zero nine one four forward
slash fl
over you adrian i think it's my bike
i hope um i trust you can hear me chair
first of all if you just confirm that
that'd be great
yes i can hear you
doing down that end yeah if you want me
to speak up chair then do please
let me know but i'll i'll speak a bit
hopefully a bit more clearly and more
loudly so that hopefully helps
just before i go into the
presentation shall just do a brief
introduction reminding members of the
elements of the application that are
adrian could you just uh hold fire for a
moment please sorry there's an echo i
don't know
something that's been left switched on
behind us
does this need switching off please
[Music]
do you still get the echo
can we just defer for a few minutes
chairman over here try and get this
sorted
i don't know if you heard what i said
previously chair but i'll i'll try and
speak more clearly and loudly which
hopefully will help you in the council
chamber
before i go on to the visuals charles
just do a brief introduction to update
members on the pertinent issues but
before firstly changes referring members
to the late comments report was issued
yesterday
and most importantly in that ask members
to note the comments made by the dolphin
wildlife trust
this application chair seeks to
see its consent to spread soil on an
area of land increases in height
from
approximately 400 millimeters to a
maximum height of a thousand millimeters
ie one meter
it is proposed to use soil from
elsewhere on the holding from a site
granted consent for housing
although if approved this application
could stand alone and be implemented by
using soil materials from elsewhere
development plan policies in this case
chair seek to ensure that the
countryside is protected from
inappropriate development that would
adversely impact its turrets and
appearance
officers conclude share that view of the
limited nature of the proposal that the
reason set out in the report the
proposal would not harm the character
appearance of the area that there are no
other considerations that outweigh that
therefore that's led us to recommend
approval of the application
specifically chair it should be noted
that there are no technical objectors
raising concerns about the application
and nothing in respect of this
application affects the permissions
referred to for the housing site close
by and the draw conditions and elements
of that would remain standalone and need
to be addressed in their own right
finally chen just for the sake of
completeness
whilst all the late representations have
been put in the pack that's been sent to
members
officers were copied into an email sent
yesterday by mrs evans who will
i believe um address you this afternoon
and that email was sent to the mp at lee
rowley and also to councillor armitage
raising various matters
however as the email was not addressed
to officers
it's not been affected as such and put
in our late comments report but most of
the points raised by mrs evans in it
were included in any case
in the late comments that she sent to us
which were included in the late comments
report
just go through the
visuals changes to remind members of the
site visit of yesterday the application
site in this case
this area of land here
the previous application for retention
of the soil dispersal
is this area here and just for the sake
of the
scene a second this is the public
footpath in which those photographs were
taken and the reference and the trees
here chair again just for sake of
completeness
this is the site that's been granted
consent for housing that's been referred
to
and shared the application site outlined
in red and the land owned or controlled
by the applicant outlined in blue
and we'll see that the area
chair that will be
reprofiled by the soil is this area here
we do have two cross sections
a b which we'll see first then cd which
we'll see second the levels that are
shown here reference the existing levels
and the proposed levels as i say it's
graded from
one of the
elements that is about 400 millimeters
higher than existing to the central
point approximately here which is one
meter higher
the profile a b as you can see there
chair that's showing the the one meter
increase in height
and then the cross-section cd showing
increase in height long ways through the
application site
and finally share just a couple of
photographs this is these are taken from
the footpath as i've mentioned
and the
depression in the ground is this area
just here and these are the trees from
the background so it would be this area
of land that would be recreated and
finally change just another photograph
of slight slightly more close up of that
site this is the area here so you can
just make out the existing depression
in the land
i believe that's all the photographs
chair thank you
thank you
we'll move on to the speakers next
and the first speaker i have on is an
objector mr mike mccann if you'd like to
take a seat at the table
three minutes when you're ready
good afternoon everybody
the first point i'd like to make is that
i have absolutely no objection in
principle to the proposal to spread soil
on an agricultural field to make it easy
to manage
my concern is the donor site where the
soil is being sourced from
the donor site has conditional planning
permission for 10 bungalows to be built
which is as far as i'm aware the
conditions are still outstanding
if the top soil is stripped off the
donor field
before the outstanding conditions are
satisfied
then in my view some of the evidence
pertaining to those conditions may
disappear
this will be the second time
that this site has been disturbed in
this way
if this is allowed to go ahead at this
time
i fear that the housing development
might be allowed to go ahead without the
conditions being properly satisfied
the due press process may not be
properly followed and effectively the
development work will have already
started
i repeat i have no problem with the
principle of the application but surely
it cannot be allowed to go ahead until
all the conditions
related to the donor site of properly
satisfied
thank you
thank you are there any questions
no thank you you'd like to take a seat
and i believe our next speaker's the
agent dominic cooney
thank you you have three minutes when
you're ready
thank you chair
[Music]
the purpose of this
purpose of this planning application is
twofold one to avoid the need for 85
loads of soil being shipped off the site
in hgvs on the roads through the village
and the surrounding areas
and two to instead use this soil to make
an existing dip in the field slightly
less deep to make it easier to farm the
land there
it's a win-win situation with
agricultural improvement of the land
combined with reduced carbon dioxide
emissions from road transport
you will have seen in the late items
report before you that the wildlife
trust is now happy with the application
and the recommended conditions for
reasonable avoidance measures
the site where the soil is to be removed
from has both outline planning
permission and reserve matters approval
and
we completely understand the concerns of
the objectors that this application will
somehow circumvent the pre-commencement
conditions on those permissions or mean
that the necessary information will not
have to be provided and this is simply
not the case
it's clear in the report that all of the
pre-commencement conditions must be
discharged on those applications
otherwise the permission will be
rendered invalid
in fact the neighbours will not be aware
but much of the work has already been
done on those conditions and the
planning department has been kept fully
informed along the way
archaeology badger surveys
appointment of an artist for the public
art commission
sustainable drainage systems
all that is left to do is to submit all
of this information in a formal
discharge of conditions application and
pay the fee
in relation to the potential for lead
levels in the soil environmental health
have stated no objections because the
soil is moving from one part of the farm
to another and the end use would still
be agricultural
the excess soil needs to be removed from
the development site to accommodate the
changing levels the access road as well
as the underground stormwater crates
we respectfully ask the committee to
approve this application today to make
sensible use of this soil elsewhere on
the farm thank you chair
thank you are there any questions
counselor armitage
yeah it's uh
how far are you uh
about uh
satisfying the conditions on the other
side are you well on the way yeah a lot
a lot of work has been done over the
last two years the the previous
application
with some of the soil removed was part
of the archaeological investigations yes
i remember that
will it be drained uh where you put in
the soil i mean it's going to be a yard
deep at the thing are you going to drain
that
it's
up to a meter in the middle of the dip
obviously and then feathering out to
nothing at the edges
the existing field drainage will remain
as it is on that field oh cool yeah
right
it's no change basically in greenfield
runoff rates
thank you any other questions
no thank you if you'd like
are there any questions for the officers
council hancock
thank you chair i just have one because
this is actually
quite concerning because it does mislead
us i don't necessarily think it changes
the overall view
but in 8 13 to 8 15 it actually says
that the environmental health officer
has not raised objections
that's not actually true because the
email from the environmental health
officer
says no objections to the proposals in
principle which is a caveated statement
and very different it's saying that they
haven't actually had the detail
to assess that properly
so i think we need to be very very
careful how we're presenting information
to members here because if that hadn't
been picked up we could be talking about
movement of contaminated soil
could you hear that adrian
afraid i didn't hear any of that jam
sorry
i heard council hancock's
comment but i didn't hear anything but i
presume when kevin hancock finished
speaking about nothing subsequently
i i'm asking for clarification adrian
over the fact that 8 13 to 8 14
tells us something different to what was
actually stated in the email that came
from the environmental health officer
what one is a caveat that one is a
caveated statement that hasn't been put
across in the office's report
if i can ask a clarification through you
from castle hancock chevy i was under
the impression that the environmental
health officer had no objections to the
proposals in principle
yeah
in principle is a caveat term that has
not been put in the report the report
actually states they have no objections
they're two very different statements
i apologize for any um
any misunderstanding
the only comment i can see from
the environmental health officer is that
they have no objections to the proposal
in principle there's no further
clarification
of that from the environmental health
officer so i'm looking for that i can
put to members chair i'm afraid
i'm just reading paragraph 8 14 again
is that the one you're on about
counseling
[Music]
i hope you can hear me chad i wonder if
counselor hancock's concerns relate to
the what's known as the donor site
rather than this site
presumably you can't hear me for
whatever reason
yeah
in in principle it is because
the the statement that's come from the
environmental health officer is that
he's only giving an in-principle
decision so he's not had the data to
make a qualified
a qualified answer
unfortunately chair i i said as i say i
have no further information i can offer
to them because other than just the
statement in full that the environmental
health office was given to me so i don't
know whether his
he has concerns about
any element of this proposal his
comments may suggest not
and that the
um what's known as the donor site would
be
controlled through the
conditions that are attached
to it and therefore before any
development of that site would take
place it would otherwise need to comply
with those conditions
the the state that the environmental
health officer is given is is purely
simply that just a single sentence i can
confirm that i have no objections to the
proposals in principle
therefore i've nothing further that
i can advise members of sharing in that
we've just
accepted that on its face that
the environmental health officer didn't
say you've got to state you've got any
concerns or want any conditions attached
to this consent and therefore
we've not sought to
probe further we've just taken comments
on let's say on their face
that's really i think
what translated
halfway down 814 it says there are
several conditions imposed on the
outline and reserved matters application
required
eho not raising objections to the
application so we're kind of taking this
presumptive
the the everything is is okay but we've
not got that clarity
just on the the issue that council eliot
have made chair
as
mr cooney um pointed out the permissions
that relate to the
housing site
will need to be addressed in their own
right
they are still outstanding and any
decision you take on this application
will have no bearing on those conditions
they stand alone and they need to be
addressed or else the development on
that site would
not be authorized not be able to
continue in the way that it was granted
commission raising
concerns about it's valentia i mean i'm
sure mr cooney is is fully aware of that
and advising his clients in respect of
that
if that's the concern that members have
shared then i'd say i can only reiterate
that the consent for the housing site
the so-called donor site
if the soil is to be moved from there to
this site
and that will that is being properly
controlled through the conditions
attached to the permission granted for
it because the soil could be taken from
that site and deposited elsewhere it
doesn't need to come to this site should
you grant permission for it this
commission does not need to be
implemented as such
thank you okay with that thank you
are there any further questions
does it
no thank you adrian
okay i'll ask um the clerk to go through
the motions again
example
uh just to remind your members uh that a
motion must be moved and seconded before
a vote is taken
if an amendment to a motion is moved and
seconded then that amendment will be
voted on first
if a motion is to be moved which goes
against the officer recommendation then
the member who has moved the motion must
give the reasons for doing so
the reasons for moving a motion against
officer recommendations
should comprise the relevant planning
issues and be supported by the evidence
as necessary
if a motion to reject officer
recommendations fails or in other words
it has not passed
that doesn't mean that the
recommendations are automatically
approved
rather you will need to take a positive
decision through a further motion in
favor of the recommendations or another
course of action
this will need to be approved by the
committee through another vote
and again members just to remind that in
terms of the my timing of the motions
these should be moved and seconded after
the committee has heard and read and
discussed the evidence before us
the chair will indicate when this point
has been reached and will then invite
motions to be put to members
and you will be reminded of this by the
clerk if any member should propose a
motion before then
thank you chair
thank you i'm opening the floor for
debate
chad i think we've gone through what we
discussed about the conditions being
satisfied before the soil's moved and if
that is the case then i'm happy with it
thank you so in which case i'll put
motion on the floor that we go
i'll
with
officer's
chair
thank you
thank you everybody
just um if i may briefly before you
take that
the vote
i
trust that that's in relation to the
revised conditions as per the later
update report which takes into account
the comments of darcher wildlife trust
yes thank you
council armitage
it does mention on
8.20 about a walk-over survey uh
for badgers and if permissions granted
uh
could we
have that put in as a condition please
okay
okay if you'd like to clarify the motion
so that is to um accept your officer
recommendations uh with the subsequent
conditions uh discussed and particularly
from the derbyshire wildlife
trust and then also uh the inclusion of
a walkover is that the essence of the
councillors
thank you are you comfortable with that
adrian
yes thanks alan okay thanks
and can we have a show of hands or take
a roll call
thank you um if you could indicate
clearly fought against or abstain cather
armitage for
casa cooper
council elliot
councillor foster four councillor hall
four
council hancock four council hearts on
four casa jones four
council liggett for councillor powell
councillor ridgeway four
and councillor rough four that's all in
favour chair thank you thank you
everybody
just a few minutes picture would that be
okay okay yep this is so we can get
people in and out safely and comfortably
if anyone wants to make a dash for the
lord please do so
we have had a lay applicant who wishes
to speak and i have granted this
applicant to speak but alan is now going
to run us through where we are at
okay thank you chair i mean along the
short of it is that mr atkinson who's uh
owner of the land as i understand it has
made a late request to speak uh the late
request being received yesterday
on item six um
tree preservation orders
in response to his request they should
have time to speak on all three
of the tpos which he's gotten interested
in
the chair has agreed that he'd be given
an extension to allow to speak for five
minutes rather than the usual three
however mr atkinson has repeated his
request
and asked to speak for nine minutes in
total so in other words three minutes
for each of the tpos
um so essentially sure thank you
thank you now i agree to five minutes i
do not agree with nine but i will go by
what you all decide to do
everybody happy with five
yeah
i think we're being more than generous
considering how late it was to come in
thank you ladies and gentlemen
okay sean will you bring him into the
room now sure
uh
right ladies and gentlemen our third
application for this afternoon
oh we got it on the screen
hello adrian
writers you're aware this application is
for a tree preservation order 280 281
282 and 283 these are the areas of trees
and woodland at ash over the application
report number is pm forward slash zero
four slirus slash two one two two twenty
forward slash ak
of the planning management development
management
over to your agent when you're ready
apologies for all that change having a
couple of uh technical problems at my
end but hopefully you can hear me and
now see me
yes
before i go into the visuals chair just
a brief introduction for the to the
report
this report asked members chair to
consider
the making of four linked provisional
tpos
into formal tpos i confirming them
and it seeks a view from members as to
whether that confirmation should take
place or not in accordance with the
scheme of delegation as in view of
objections having been received to all
four orders
it's not a decision that officers are
able to take it is one for the planning
committee
just as background chair the
members will be familiar with the
interim ashoka tpo number one which was
a
large area order made back in 1944
which due to its age has increasingly
been challenged as to its continuing
validity
and the advice that we have from the
council's legal team is that because of
its age it is increasingly difficult to
rely on it to offer protection to the
trees
as such chair officers determined to
make for
replacement orders
which in addition to others that have
been made on smaller areas of the trees
within that larger area
for ongoing protection for the trees
covered
the orders chair comprise three area
orders and one woodland order and it had
been hoped that additional work could
have been undertaken in the six-month
grace period that's given to confirm the
orders to make them more concise and
complete but unfortunately shared due to
other work pressures that's not been
possible
and therefore officers are recommending
that the four orders
are confirmed in their present form as
per the provisional making of them
the orders do need chair to be
assessed and either confirmed
or not
by the 26th of this month hence the need
to come to members at this point without
additional works we'd hope to be done
being completed
as i've said share objections to all
four orders have been received and as
set out in the report
however today in conclusion officers
have taken the view that due to the
public perception of ongoing protection
of these trees offered by the interim
order
but as the trees do along with many
others in the amber valley to the west
and southwest of ashoka they do offer
mental value officers have concluded
share that the order should be confirmed
in their provisional form i use three
area orders and one woodland order
just in terms of um
visuals chair the
interim order
covered the area that i'm just outlining
with my cursor
so it covered
a large area to the west of ashover and
the east of kelstedge
and
in 1944 when it was made it provided
protection of all those
trees within that area
and that is
a copy of the
plan that accompanied the order at that
time chair so
the outline in red
was the area covered by the order ash
over to the east and what was then a
smaller kelst edge to the west and at
the center you can
see uh
marsh green hall which is um where i
think the strategy is due to addresses
happening that's where he resides
the four orders chair comprised trees at
the born which is outlined here and
these are shown in the pack what the
reproduction isn't that fantastic which
is why i tried to present them here this
is more road
and then this is harsh green lane so
it's the air trees within that
opener ship
it's an area order on these trees to the
southwest
bashover it's being narrowly lane
more road again
more
marsh green lane there this is the born
here so
the first gpo 280 covers the area within
the trees within that area
then share an area of woodland
comprising a
area of woodland that stretches from
butts in the south here past
kelvin marsh stream farm on the left
towards the top of uh battling krypton
lane and then another order chair that
comprise the roadside trees of krypton
lane and back lane
just to give some flavor of
some of the trees that are
within those areas chair this is the
crease this photo was taken from the
crease of narrowly's lane to the left
and more lane to the right
and trees in the born
in the hedgerow at the back here the
trees in the foreground would be
covered by the area order of narrowly's
lane and more lane
and then further along these are some of
the trees um
comprising these land off crypts and
lane the roadside trees aren't shown
here but you can just make out marsh
green farm here chair this is
area of the proposed portland order that
would be in the foreground
and for the
similar location but to get the woodland
trees to the southwest up there
and then some of the trees that would
comprise the order and close to kel
stage this is another part of the
woodland order
and then finally chair just a flavor of
some of the trees back towards the boats
that would be caught by the area order
narrow east lane
thank you
i believe we only have one speaker this
afternoon mr darren atkinson
if you'd like to take the table
you have five minutes when you're ready
mr atkinson
before i start
chair obviously i did ask prior to this
meeting if i could be given the
extension if necessary and i don't
necessarily think i will need it
um to obviously have the three minutes
that i would expect to be allocated for
each individual
modification
um that was something that i was led to
believe it would be debating before i
start today
it was and it was all agreed by the
committee that five minutes would be
adequate
right okay well i'll do my best to
get through that
oh yes
[Music]
right thank you cheering members um i
found some of the land which is subject
to the proposed tpos and supported in
principle
uh the tpos which are important trees
and maybe and would be at risk uh and
may need protection
indeed i have planted several hundred
trees and over a mile of new edges in
the last few years on the land
i'm sure members acknowledge that any
tpo imposes impose generates
considerable incumbents on the
landowners who manage tpos with red tape
involved in carrying out simple works
it's on last point that i asked members
to consider the implications of this
order
there are hundreds of trees in this
order that this order would affect
you will have all read the officers
report which recommends that new tpos
should be made
and if you accept the report to be
accurate you will no doubt make those
orders as recommended
however before you decide it is
important they consider if the officers
fought report falls short in the due
process and if making of the tpos is
justified unfair
firstly on the background of the report
the actual ringtone tpo of 1944
was a provisional tpo to cover trees
after the war
we requested information on the
council's 10 reasons for that order to
establish the purpose and what we sought
to protect
we've not received any information from
officers on those fights
the report states that paragraph 1.2
that the order is reinforceable
to avoid any challenges in future years
i asked members if members today can
agree to revoke that obsolete order
i would also ask members today to
consider if new process and appropriate
methods of evaluation accord with the
1990 legislation amendments and guidance
on tpos
which have been carried out i believe
not
he offers a report at 1.7 states before
confirming any order the council should
satisfy itself that trees
would bring a reasonable degree of
immunity it is not the case here and i
will explain
the report at 1.8 is incorrect officers
are certainly not fully assessed
correctly the trees set out in the
regulated guidance thereby misleading
members on recommendations to this order
members should make particular note that
under paragraph 1.8
the officers advise and i quote only
the threes only offer significant
immunity when taken together with other
trees and woodland in the vicinity
this statement should therefore conclude
that the trees alone are not significant
to justify tpos without the other trees
and woodlands being part of that order
this order would be justly imposed
at
tech 1.10 the statement of single land
ownership is incorrect
several landowners open part of the
mapped area and have not been notified
or unaware of this order
paragraph 1.10 suggests any such order
might be afforded an interim protection
any proposed interim time must be
defined and not allowed to indefinitely
otherwise landowners will be left with
no accurate defined tpo
such an ancient would in this case been
considered unjust but it would assume
that all the trees outside will notice
which officers consider significant
would be included
the officer states and i quote again
that these trees hold no greater value
than others within the asheville area
one of those other trees referred to
will not have tpos imposed on them
analysts you are asked to consider this
point if the trees in this order have no
greater value why tpo should be imposed
without genuine reason and fairness to
the
landowners with regards to the team
errors themselves
tpo 281 and 283 the objection to these
is made on the following grounds
the council has failed as legally failed
to identify
[Music]
[Music]
does not follow the procedure set out in
the guidance flow chart one on tpos
council should not accept replacing a
defaulting tpo of 1944
as the reason to impose a new order
which does not accord or follow the
regulations and guidance to make tpos
the mapping evaluation
i'll leave it to the council to members
half a page after that
in evaluation and immunity and tree
conditions have not been acutely carried
out and these make orders in accordance
with the council's chosen method of
assessment when there's terrible
to process of the trees proceeded to
reserve has been undertaken by an
inexperienced fast-tracked and newly
qualified officer
the officer has no qualifications in
agriculture to correctly fully evaluate
the trees of disorder
i would ask if the
members
i'm happy to hear that everyone is it's
only a few
chickens thank you nikki thank you
the um of the air force subject to many
errors which have been raised with
officers
gpo notices have been placed on trees
that would clearly not be tpos if
correctly evaluated on the tempo
trees considered in the report are
outside the islander shows ownership
which have been considered important as
referred to in the report these have not
been part of any such order which is
unreasonable and inferior
on tpo 282 which is the woodland and
further comment
the notice caused woodland that have not
been visited
by officers effectively no
indeed inaudible areas are not even
woodland
the mapping in the order is only
inaccurate and the council have a legal
route to correct the map survey areas
that have been placed into a tpo to
afford disputes over what is encompassed
in the tpo
to summarize members you have to
consider if the making of these orders
is necessary reasonable and will refer
to the londoners if they are imposed
the main rationale on the report is for
the new tpos to replace an obsolete
temporary order
this should not be a reason to make a
new tpo
and the correct procedure under the
guidance and the flowchart of one being
carried out when it is unlikely that
these orders would be preferred today
it is important to consider errors in
the report of evaluating trees correctly
we should occur the regulations guidance
methods that he demonstrated that it
does not
the assessment should have been clearly
and diligently undertaken by a qualified
person and members should resist to make
an order where in this case it is
misconceived
it is important to consider whether the
reference port places other trees which
are not part of this order
those trees appear to have been a key
and intrinsic consideration of worthless
evaluation
without what
do not have significant importance to
justify tpos
these trees are the same as many of
those
trees that don't have tpos in asheville
members finally were asked if the
injections made today have genuine cause
to be raised
also to consider if the absolute tpo
should be replaced without being subject
to an accurate evaluation process
fairness to the landlords who will be
affected
members has to consider the injections
raised today
and asked not to make an order that has
been inadequately evaluated under
regulation guidance does not occur with
the legislation
thank you are there any questions
i've just got one simple question chair
i mean and it's if you'll afford me it
it
i know there's a
bunch over there doing a thing with
trees that can get in blanket tpo on
everything is that part of this
what are you speaking about
well to my knowledge this is totally
different okay thank you
no further questions
thank you just like to take a
seat are there any questions for the
officers
yeah i'd just like to ask that self same
thing with adrian then because i believe
or indeed william might know there's
somebody somewhere got a quite a large
blanket tpo on a lot of things in ash
over and i wonder if that's part and
parcel of this
okay i'm trusting that you can you can
hear me first first and foremost just in
answer to that the
many of the points you've heard that mr
atkinson raised are perhaps relevant
towards that other um site actually but
um yes the provisional tpo 278 was made
on a
significant area of woodland to the
southwest of our show were near to four
gates but due to the cancellation of the
august committee meeting it wasn't
possible to bring that to members for
confirmation so that order is now for
them so there is no
tpo 278
it is
um
i believe that's the area trees that
council eliot is referring to
subsequent to that i've been asked to
meet with the landowner in that case who
raises many similar queries
that you've heard mr atkinson raise
this afternoon
i've not yet done that
but in short the answer to cancer
elliot's question check is these trees
are not the same as those trees that
have also
been a request made to blanket tpo
thank you cats for
hermitage uh yes uh adrian uh
uh mr atkinson relates to the way that
uh especially 282
uh
was
that no officer has been had a look and
the regulation guidance
uh
hasn't been adhered to
and he also
makes comments that the person who
has done the others
are not qualified to do so could you uh
uh enlighten me on this please
just first of all and jim may be able to
uh comment on this if i get it wrong but
the legislation chair purely and simply
as far as i read it gives the power to
local planning authorities to make tree
preservation orders
in the interests of protecting trees
in the wider sense so that's as far as i
understand it where the legislation lies
i believe that uh mr atkinson's speaking
of this afternoon is talking about other
guidances how that takes place
and
bearing in mind the
resources available to
the planning team at the moment that
work has been done as far as possible in
conjunction with other work
but as far as i'm concerned
officers are following the broad outline
of the guidance in that the orders are
made
and provisionally and full assessments
done before any confirmed or not but
currently
i'm certainly not um qualified to
undertake arboricultural work i've no
formal arboricultural assessment
and i'm not aware despite having
considerable experience in
similar related matters i'm not aware
that
my colleague who's assist me on this has
either although i may be doing her
a disservice
the the issue that's raised by cancer
armitage chair is
is um if members feel it relevant to
this instance does
affect all other tpos and all of the
tree works that we're doing as planning
officers
um in the interim as well so
similar query and comment would
be
and pertinent although i do understand
that
it is the intention in the near future
to seek
the appointment of an arboriculture
officer and that has been agreed by
members and will proceed in the coming
months but short answers counter arms
question i don't believe that the
council has heard
in law in provisionally making the order
and potentially confirming them
the guidance as far as i'm concerned
is being
followed
but
by in terms of myself certainly by
someone who doesn't have any arboric
cultural qualification just experience
thank you are there any further
questions counselor cooper
uh adrian i think it's along the same
point um
mr atkinson mentioned that landowners
had not been notified
um is that correct
all right then the um the making of the
orders is undertaken by
by the legal team
and
um they're reliant on on the legal team
following due process and
undertaking the necessary searches etc
i've i've not followed that up further
to um the query that's been raised with
you this afternoon i met mr atkinson
last
wednesday i think it was with my
colleague alice
and he did raise it at that point but
i've not received anything in writing
from him to that effect subsequently as
far as i'm aware
and so
the the order in terms of it being made
and miss track goodson believes there
are other landowners who should have
been informed and jim would have to
advise on how that affects the validity
of the provisional orders
um i think if that is the case there
have been landowners that haven't been
notified the um
at the making of the order that
that would be a concern but i can't
comment on whether that is the
case or not we would have to i'd have to
go back and um
speak to the the officer who who made
the order and did all the process
prior to the making of the order
that's right i can't comment
at this meeting whether um
all the owners
have been correctly uh notified of the
making of the order or not
thank you are there any further
questions counsellor
um i think there are too many questions
to be honest
um i think we find ourselves in a
situation where
information is probably too scamped to
make a decision
um
i think that um
speaker raises some legitimate concerns
which need addressing
before we can make a decision
um i'm always just as as a comic chair
if i may be allowed to make it is that
when you do a blanket tpo
it does put a loss of odours on a
landowner
um who has a woodland
and that every single tree
if it is tpo'ed and
every time something happens to one
you've got to apply to do something with
it
um but because i um i think there are
too many unanswered questions that have
been raised
um i would suggest um and i do this with
a certain amount of trepidation really
because i don't only agree
that in this case we should defer
because we need more information about
how
and what evaluation was made in each
particular case
um and that we look into the other
matters that have been raised in terms
of ownership as well
so that would uh i would like to
recommend that chair
thank you i know we sort of
jumped a bit from protocol but i think a
lot of people were nodding their heads
with that um so
can i just ask for a roll call that we
go for the deferment
so it's deferred um so that additional
information can be uh gathered about um
who's actually been informed what
evaluation has taken place as well
yeah just just before you were you moved
to um to vote on that i'm not
necessarily seeking to persuade members
to to do something different i think the
points that have been made
are valid and points made by counselor
pal it's just that um i think that if
that was the decision taken by members
it would be incumbent on us officers
then to
to work with the the various landowners
um in the near term to come back to you
with alternative orders because these
four orders will fall on the 26th of
october
therefore we will be coming back to
members potentially with with new orders
in respect of the trees
i think
my own view would be that the risk in
this instance of
undertaking the action that council
powell has put to you and to members is
limited because only so much work to
trees can be undertaken without
requiring the necessary felling and
forestry commission licenses and
approval so i think the risk is limited
but just
members are aware that as of the 26th of
october the trees would have no formal
and tree preservation protection but as
i say my view in this instance is that
the stance that council powers put you
is not unreasonable
but it would leave that small risk that
works could be undertaken although um i
believe that mr ankerson is a is a
responsible landowner and would not seek
to take advantage of that decision
should members pursue it
council
adrian is there any way we could extend
that so as we keep that tpo whilst we
look into the to the rest of the issues
the only way that we could do that would
be um
to to make a further provisional order
or orders and
i'm happy to to work with
jim and his team on that
and we could do that in due course but
as of the 26th of october
and without member approval the
orders will fall and so we will be
coming back to members with new order a
new order or new orders further to the
investigation addressing of all those
other issues my own view in this
instance as i say is that the risk is
small because i i believe that mr
accused it is a responsible landowner as
you can put in the substitution you take
and um significant tree planting and
management in any case but there is that
that small risk although as i say i
think it is
it's small because there are other
controls over large-scale works and two
trees in this respect
i hope that that's how all you are so
i'm not seeking to dissuade members from
following the the um
uh motion that counts the power's put
forward i'm just asking members to note
there is that
implication
through the chair then adrian i think i
agree with you completely you know i
mean not being a responsible landowner i
don't think he'd be here
but i think we need to also be a
responsible council and safeguard
those tpos until we make some decision
on what's happening going forward
councillor hall
thank you yeah adrian you talk about mr
atkinson being a responsible
uh landowner but we also hear that the
uh trees are in the ownership of various
people
so
again it's something we have to bear in
mind that if
um
the tpo
well
this temporary order does fall on the
26th then
we could be
leaving the trees um
open to
being cut down i guess in effect so it's
something
that
we all have to bear in mind is there any
way if if we do it could it uh for
deferment could it be that
it's only deferred if you get an
extended order is that um like something
we could put in as some conditions
i think as far as that's concerned share
through you um it would be a matter of
us and remaking provisional orders as
speedily as possible to
provide that
um interim protection that the council
and council allies have talked about
whether that could be done by the 26th
of october and therefore restart the six
months would not just be dependent on
myself and colleagues would also be
dependent on
um jim and his team as well reissuing
the orders but that would in in
following that procedure it would then
would allow the issues that members are
concerned about to to be reviewed and be
brought back in a more timely fashion
hopefully without the
impediment of
worldwide pandemics to get in the way of
allowing a speedy committee hearing
okay councillor
yeah i wholeheartedly agree with what's
being said i think you know we do need
to preserve these trees until we get
more information
so yes i think we need to see if we can
ex get the extension done as soon as
possible preserve those trees for six
months because like council hall says
there are other owners there that may
not be as responsible and that's no
disrespect to to them
so i think we need to protect those
trees until we get the information we
need and then bring it back to this
council so yes i wholeheartedly agree
so i can be absolutely clear of this i
believe that
i'm hearing that members are saying that
not to confirm the four orders before
you this afternoon as per counselor
powell's comments
but um as speedly as possible to reissue
four provisional orders and then address
these issues during the six-month
consideration of that that's what i'm
understanding from the debate i don't
want in any way to misunderstand the
wishes of
members but that that's what i'm hearing
that would follow
um or take a a vote on council powell's
motion to
not confirm the orders but take a
decision to to reach the orders as
speedily as possible to mitigate that
risk as much as possible and then
address these issues within the
six-month period it would then have
following the making of those reissued
orders that's what i'm hearing and
that's what i'm understanding is the
case
i i would welcome clarification if
that's not right
i think we're all in agreement with with
that
yeah
do you want to do a quick roll call then
nikki
thank you chair said the motion on the
table is to defer the planning
application
yeah
cather armitage for
if we get the provisional temporary
order in place
ridgeway four and cancel rough four
unanimous chair thank you
very briefly
that will be part and parcel of the
process going forward now
thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen item
eight section 106 agreement and this is
going to be presented by adrian
yes thank you chair i
hope that the the report before members
is a self-explanatory
chair first of all my apologies that
it's taken us this long to come back to
members further to the last
consideration of this
11 months ago that's
longer than we would have hoped but hope
members understand that there's been
mitigating circumstances in this case
the report has
you've read it chair and as the
appendices work outlines
and three elements first of all where
we've received monies in respect of
the um
section 106 agreements secondly where
we receive monies but we are
seeking to um sorry where development
started where we're seeking to recruit
those ones and finally where this
money's outstanding where development
hasn't yet triggered the payment of them
and as is customary we've set out in
appendix a
which is in the supplementary papers for
red items whereby
the time period for spending the money
is coming up to conclusion and that's
set out in your papers chair at
paragraph 1.5 those four items where the
money is
needing to be spent within the next
couple of years and in all those cases
chair officers are monitoring those
situations where necessary organizing
the spending the proper spending of the
money
so
that's all i intend to say chair if
there are any points that members do
wish to to raise then please do so but i
would like to
to thank the work that members have
undertaken and
jim and his colleagues as well as those
in the planning team for getting us to
this position and for continually
monitoring and following up the payments
where we've not received them and for
ensuring where we have got outstanding
payments we are seeking those in most
instances receiving them without needing
to pursue formal means
thank you jay
thank you councillor foster
uh thank you chair
uh
thank you mr kirpa thank you for that uh
this new system we've got in place now
is
is much clearer and it's much easier i
think for members to be able to look at
this i think in the past before we had
this traffic light system and the
the three separate uh tables it was much
harder and very often you'd been
planning and this just go by with a nod
uh rather than this being the place to
actually question when um you know an
update on each particular item of um
each particular
piece of 106 monies
um so that was the whole principle
behind making these these changes so
members could look at it and question
each item
and moving on from that
uh i would like to pick up three items
but before
uh i also remember that during the
design of this new system
there was still a lack of clarity
between whether
so uh there's still a fair uh
for myself a lack of clarity between
when planning would stop looking at
these and when they would stop dealing
with outstanding monies and when legal
would take it on
uh to chase it i've had that discussion
a few times so it's that demarcation
online which is still in my mind that's
still unclear when it moves from one
department to the other
uh so those are my comments on that
uh moving on to actual
uh let me unlock my ipad again moving on
to actual uh items on page 61.
that's not on the paper it doesn't say
the page number on the paper but on page
61 uh
item number 47
uh
it's it's one that we know about it's a
white house morton and it's 113 000
uh
which uh
was due uh in 2016. uh let's send in
2016 reminder letters uh then we've got
uh mr fields and to write a report not
to pursue the amount uh 2021
um
i'm not fully aware of the history
behind this one although i'm sure it has
been just discussed before but the
response the report to not pursue this
money
is still to be produced as of uh
as of august 2021 so that's the first
one i'd like to ask for an update on
when we're having this report
and what we're doing about whether this
um whether this
money is to be chased or how we're going
to write it off i think it's important
that members know about this once i
think this is the place where we do
discuss this and chase this uh i've then
got two further items after that
okay do you want to address this one
first i'm not sure which one's going to
take it up first
like if i can start you know and then
perhaps you can
address any um
issues that are not
addressed correctly just in terms of the
first comment that council foster made
the
process
that we have agreed with colleagues in
the games legal team is that
the planning team will monitor sites so
we monitor sites um ideally on a twice a
year basis that's been slightly
disjointed over the past
12 months but that is our our intention
now further to that we send out
two letters
seeking payment so um
um i choose to try and choose my term
correctly but uh but and a kind approach
you can similarly approach would you
like to pay the money to us please
after the second letter we pass it to
colleagues in the the legal team who
pursue that money on the behalf of the
council because that's when it gets to
situations if they don't pay there's a
breach of contract and therefore the
council has powers to to pursue that
through
legal means
just in terms firstly of um white house
morton
there has been um consideration of this
this issue
and
um
it's purely and simply because i've not
been able to
to complete the report i'm afraid that
it's not come before members but i will
discuss that with colleagues and we will
seek to do that expeditiously and
perhaps uh jim might give me a nod or
not perhaps over the next couple of
cycles we'll put together what's needed
and bring it back to members but to meet
jim's input into the report to do that
but my apologies to to members for not
having completed that
in
time in a timely way
i think actually it's probably
um my fault i think i was the one who
was going to bring this report however
um
have not been able to
um
this was something that we discussed or
it must be about a year ago when um
when this um
the section 106
report was brought to members
of the last time it was brought this was
raised and um
it was explained that the
reason why we struggled to um
recover the money or
obtain the money is that the developer
is no longer in existence
and there was discussion about maybe
chasing the individual homeowners
however i think members were
um very reluctant to go down that route
and
therefore i think what is actually
needed is a formal decision not to
pursue
um the matter
it's so
in effect it's really a tidy up exercise
which we so we just need that decision
in order to get this and this item off
the of the books
and it is something that will need to be
done sooner rather than later and we'll
endeavour to get report on committee for
you to make that decision
thank you chair uh thanks for that uh
appreciate that uh my concern i i i
understand the the explanation i've got
that uh but i think it's something we do
need to chase uh quickly um
and these reports do need uh producing i
know there's been pressures you know uh
with all our pressures uh
lately uh whichever whatever area we're
working but um we've got the public
looking at us
uh with uh with things like this so
that's why it's important uh that we're
on top of these things
uh that's my view on that and that's how
we need these reports and we need to be
if we do decide to write it off we write
it off and it's made clear on it being
where they're hanging around
the next one is the one below it which
is reference 53 which is the royal hotel
eckington
this is a smaller amount this is 9000.
if we look at the latest comments on it
at work completed on site uh aka i'm
assuming that's yourself mr kirkham sent
letter 22nd of july 19.
um now i know other things might have
happened on this and i know there'll be
an update a verbal update
but the whole idea of these this system
uh is that we can look at it and get um
you know
immediately and the public can they can
know exactly what's happening with this
now if that is the latest uh
uh thing that's happened a letter sent
in july 19 if it is i'm sure there's a
story to it not sorry a report to it but
if that's the last uh we you know it's
that is quite poor
uh i feel it is anyway so uh if you give
me an update on that one whoever is it
is on that
chair unfortunately i don't know the
details sufficient to
respond to you now i'm afraid but i can
either um report back to to members at
the next planning committee or i can
write to council foster independently in
the meantime when i've you know had a
chance to look into the matter and the
reasons why
the situation is as it is and it's not
been pursued but i i can't answer at
this moment i'm afraid
thank you chair that's fine mr kirkham
uh it's fine if you bring it back rather
than to me personally if you bring it
back to the uh the committee it's
absolutely fine
um
it might be i'm sure it will have been
dealt with but it's a matter of keeping
these up to date these
uh
this whole system was was designed to
for us to be able to look at it and
anyway next one is on the next page uh
which is reference 54 and that's the
ridgeway craft center
uh that's uh affordable housing and
monetary impairment 77 thousand
and uh
for those i'm ready i'll let you read
through the comments there
and we've got chasing letters uh jf i
sent a chase letter on november 2020
asked legal for contentious department
to recover money april 2021 that's april
2021 reports still to be produced and
that's
august 21.
so to me it looks like the last we've
done on that
the last we've actually done is a chase
letter in november 2020
uh which is you know that's a that's a
while back now
and that's for 77 000. that's the last
it says on this report the last contact
we've had with um
with uh the ridgeway craft center
development
however the developer has
denied all liability
paid the money under the six months
experiment
therefore the um the matter has now been
referred to court so court proceedings
have commenced
i think they were lodged uh sometime in
august so we're currently waiting for a
um
report from the county court
so we are we are moving on with with
that uh and um
i think this item just does need to be
updated for the next time so the things
that things are moving on
thank you if i can just just add to that
if i may
um
my apologies if um things have moved on
since the report was first produced it
was intended to bring this report to
members in august but as members will
recall that the committee was cancelled
then so as i wasn't present in september
committee i rebranded the the report for
this meeting and may have been remiss of
me not to have brought it and checked
all the the advice and as of the the
august committee so i apologize for that
but that's the reason why maybe some of
the
updates aren't as
updated as they may otherwise have been
thank you chair uh thanks for the uh
for the report on that and the
explanation i think the key thing is
here for me is that these these need to
be updated uh so we know exactly what's
happening on because it's our job to
look at these and it's our job not to
knock them through but it's our job to
ask questions on them and make sure
you know that they've been looked at
correctly can you just ask when the next
report will come through because i know
you said earlier that
for different reasons it's been a while
since you've brought us one of these 106
reports there's no reason why a report
like this shouldn't be brought for me at
the end
of every uh property meeting because
it's the same report
with just updated notes
it's not like you know it's and then we
can be on top of it all the time
for me uh i i know we probably have to
seek other members views on this but
rather than us receiving this in another
six months
this for example you could bring us the
same report but updated at the next
planning meeting it's a it's not only a
start
thank you
okay just in in response to council
foster it's currently
the request of planning committee that
we bring report to members every six
months
that's the current current request and
therefore this report
is is five months
out of date and hopefully in this
instance members
understand that the reasons why that why
that may have been the case that's
currently the process
and clearly take members views on how
often you would like the report and how
much in debt you would like it
and my only concern about bringing it
every month is that leaves us
limited time to actually turn it around
between the close of one committee and
the deadline for the next committee
which is only two weeks away for us in
preparing the papers that's my only
concern about that
chair but clearly um members wish the
reports to be brought on a more regular
basis than every six months and that
that is something that can be arranged
would you be quite happy to see this on
a quarterly basis
if the the group is happy with that and
no counselor richway's got a comment to
make next
i hope through the chat i was just going
to say every two months maybe might be
better
um
but i'm happy either way two months or
quarterly
and if anyone's got anything particular
that they need to keep an eye on in
their own district i mean this can
always be flagged up through the offices
quite quickly
yes chess certainly um
members don't need to leave it before
there's a formal report to planning
committee to to raise issues of 106 is
with officers it and there was
particularly concerned of members the
report is
it's with you and you therefore you have
an upstate position on the 106 as if
there are
issues in the inter input and certainly
um
a quarterly report that would go back to
where we were maybe a couple of years
ago and certainly that
in terms of updating votes and making
progress
will be
my opinion more deliverable by officers
to provide a more meaningful report to
members for what i mean in the hands of
members on that of course
okay would
members be happy with quarterly
councillor [ __ ]
just
i just wanted to ask adrian a question
that one is one of the one here if i can
yeah sure um
number 41 the wool pack at sherland
um i noticed that we've got
supposedly
an installment a monthly installment of
just under 2000.
uh i wonder if that is being paid
and i wonder why because one of those
properties sold for 850 000
just just in terms of whether it is
being paid and i see jim's advice on
this but that was
an agreement that's been reached with
the the council's legal team and so i
presume that the monies are being paid
up i don't know for certain
just in terms of the
agreements
the
proposal was something that was
suggested to us by the
um applicant owners developers as a way
of making payments because they didn't
feel as though it was possible to make
the
lump sum payments so that was the
agreement that was arranged with the
developers in this instance to secure
them when he went over an installment
basis rather than being paid as a lump
sum
okay so we'll go back to my earlier
question is everyone happy with
quarterly
i i can't
i can't confirm
whether they've been paying the money
so he can't understand you can you speak
up a bit further
i can't confirm
whether or not there have been
the
that will be the question we need to
raise with uh i think they almost
financed
i think we get the gist of that general
thank you
certainly in that instance chair of
council league it's happy with this i
can raise that with
the legal human right to uh and when
i've had the the response so we can
advise council liggett and as an
individual member on that instance that
the money is being paid but of course we
can then update the comments section
when we next bring this back to members
should you determine a quarterly update
is appropriate and the next update
will be in january therefore we can
bring that potential members but in the
meantime i propose i write to council
liggett and give her an update firstly
okay adrian thank you
nikki would you just like a show of
hands for that
can just have quick sharp hands for
quarterly
everyone's happy thank you
thank you for that asian thank you mark
for uh the work that you've done on this
with the offices
and we can move on to a gender item nine
planning appeals lodged and determined
i don't know if you wish for you to say
anything or not
does anyone any questions for these
no you're off the hook this time adrian
quite a quite a slim version of this
report this month chess that's that's
good on so many levels
thank you
and as for item 10 matches of urgency i
do not have any so oh i've got a hand
raised council
um i hope i can have this now because um
we keep having this problem with tpos
and tree work
and i've spoken to a dr rinder who is a
member of the institute of chartered
foresters and he's quite happy to put it
in writing that we do need a qualified
arboriculturalist to determine whether
trees should be filled and work carried
out
that position is actually being
advertised so that we've got it on a
planning team
so then we'll have a full complement of
everything we need
thank you thank you all ladies and
gentlemen see you next time
you